the first story of their house has been
rebuilt two years after the last war I
manan dreams in Barry's house in beta
noon in northern Gaza was completely
destroyed during the Israel Gaza
conflict they are rebuilding it with the
support of the UN relief and Works
Agency for Palestine refugees the
11-member family is dependent on the
help of silver steel they're not really
happy purchased other people have only
just started rebuilding even those whose
houses were destroyed in 2008 in 2012 I
thought it would take was at least 10
years but she I show us Nina no Monsieur
Mallah the reconstruction process is
complicated and lengthy Israel restricts
construction materials from entering the
Gaza Strip which is ruled by Hamas the
restrictions are aimed at stopping armed
groups from getting their hands on
cement and steel more than 140,000
refugee homes were damaged in the last
war but there's also a shortage of aid
money up to now almost 400 families
received full reconstruction package so
400 families now they are living in
their new houses but now you are talking
about 47 thousand four hundred families
who lost whole shelter so it's a li
stage of reconstruction free
construction is not the only task of the
UN eight agency in Gaza the UN or w/ei
also looks after schools health care and
provides food age and it's been doing so
for over 60 years like here in the
shotty refugee camp where basic food
supplies are being distributed today
some 930,000 people rely on the age and
the number is growing the blockade by
Israel and Egypt and three wars have
made the situation worse but not
everyone is satisfied with the help
labtec fish it's never enough we only
get this every three to four months it's
like a painkiller for the symptoms
nothing more than that let's get no job
dr. Annika the UN RWAs fiercest critic
is the Israeli government
there is absolutely no doubt that living
the Palestinians in the situation of
refugees forever and ever only serves to
perpetuate the conflict and it increases
hatred and incitement against Israel but
observers in Gaza see things differently
well and no existence of the UN or w/ei
in the Palestinian territories is a main
reminder that the refugee issue is still
there and it's still unresolved another
nap call the it larger in Mezei lat
William to huddle the shin berry family
wants to move into their new house
within the next two months but the fear
of an uncertain future remains I hello
nobody nothing big as soon as it's
finished we'll move in but who knows
maybe there'll be another war a month
later and our house will be destroyed
again and will be homeless once more the
chopped Rodman's d the UN or wa would
then be called upon again like it
husband for 60 years